this here is a darkling beetle it lives
out here in the vast desert of Northwest
Utah and he's on the move where - I
don't have a clue but I can tell you
about the town he's leaving behind
welcome to loose in Utah there's
abandoned cars weeds once in a while
train will pass through yep there's not
a whole lot here and loosen well except
for this man but who is this man this
man who lives in an airplane hangar who
flies a Cessna to get to his closest
friend who is this man this man who
lives in the middle of nowhere who lives
25 miles from this bar with this man
inside who owns a bunch of guns works
with machines made this thing who is
this man
my name is Ivo I got a scare and this is
what I left as you've gathered this man
isn't from around loosen he grew up in
Czechoslovakia before the fall of the
USSR he didn't like it much it's kind of
hard to do anything the Communist
sweater and powder that cannot have your
own business it's becoming difficult to
fly that so high camera I didn't feel
like I could be myself he really wanted
to leave the country but it wasn't easy
there was an item cookin they like have
a machine gun towers and barbed wire to
keep you in they like to keep you so
when he was 24 he escaped the country
the only way he knew how
by flying across the border in his self
built airplane so I drove up close to
the border between Austria and some time
like at 3 o'clock in the morning I took
off and I just glide it over to Austria
Maxon myself Vienna International
Airport and I landed that and then I
just showed them my expired passport and
I asked for asylum and the world took
notice I guess they're never seen
anything like that before so I think
they liked it I liked it either then
moved to Los Angeles and built up a
successful airplane propeller business
but even LA couldn't fit his big ideas I
kind of needed a place to put my other
idea which is how to do it in the middle
of the city that's how I found this
place in Utah it was for sale so I
bought it and I've been here four or
gate here
what was I those big idea that brought
him to loosen well it's behind that door
over there
[Music]
inside sits and a propeller flying
machine able to lift off and land
vertically and basically an airplane
helicopter hybrid of sorts it's kind of
funny looking but the damn thing
actually flies so what's out of those
next big project a solar-powered
aircraft an innovative propeller design
some kind of new way to fly the next big
one is that the speeder gun idea army
Chuck Chile it was better than I thought
that doesn't always work that way come
come I get the really bad idea even
while inventing new spear guns and the
like ivo still finds the time to get out
of the house in fact that Tim over there
hiking on the side of a mountain it's
just him nature and his customized rifle
I think the gunner is mean because of
the mountain lions
however treacherous the hike it's always
worth it you get a good view of loosen
it actually looks pretty nice from here
don't it you know I still wonder why did
that darkman be to let her leave this
place maybe Leeson wasn't right for the
little guy
maybe it's escaped into the next place
where it can be itself farrago though
looks like this might be his last stop
come at Eliezer this is what's always
for me
I kept escaping until I skipped to
listen and now I don't have anywhere
else for a stead I promise tugging here
[Music]
well no ice also it throws if you think
about it the paper airplane you folded
in middle school horrible design but
I've thrown a paper airplane 214 feet
I'm John Collins
I am the paper airplane guy world record
holder for a paper aircraft distance
[Music]
come here we got the record was 2012 it
was you know one of the great days in my
life actually you know I look back at my
child being born in the world record
those are great moments for me I named
the world record plane after my wife the
name of the design is Suzanne this is
how you fold Suzanne you start with the
short side of the paper out observation
put it against the right now when you
want a little better get an X in the
after that is to say all right hand
write down the top of the plane you fold
the plane in half it's just eight simple
folds there are a lot of different kinds
of folding techniques and a lot of
different kinds of paper airplane
there's planes that boomerang back there
are planes that are made to fly straight
very far there are planes that are made
of stay in the air for a long time every
great paper airplane distance or time a
lot has very accurate bullet most people
want to know how I got into paper
airplanes and the reality as I never got
out of them I am curious by nature I
love math and science the cool thing
about paper airplanes is it's a way to
actually discover something real about
flight what most people don't know is
that we don't know the exact cause and
effect for lift every little paper
airplane throw is like a little science
experiment here's the laboratory right
here in your hand that you could use to
do real science teachers kind of don't
like kids to do paper airplanes it has
this bad boy kind of renegade reputation
if they could discover that paper
airplanes actually are signs if they're
doing science and having
do it I think that's incredible
breakthrough paper airplane throwing
class yes jet liners are basically
flying home it's a field pressure
canister it's incredibly strong it will
last practically forever
I'm Bruce Campbell and you're inside the
cockpit area of my 727 home I can
appreciate that some folks might feel a
bit isolated or it might simply strike
them as an unusual living environment
but for me it's always felt completely
natural entry is via the after stairs
which are retractable and are retracted
would arrive for an extended time the
aft area of the aircraft now is my
living space my very primitive shower is
located there
the two natural apt laboratories are
both functional sleeping quarters
they're in the form of a simple futon
sofa and bench where I spend lots of
time embellishing elements of the
aircraft jet liners retire at the rate
of about three per day for the most part
I think we shred them and then we spin
around 180 degrees and make a home after
having just shredded an aerospace class
home size structure if you are an
extraterrestrial looking down on this
behavior you'd wonder whether the
species has all his marbles in place or
not people have asked me whether it
crashed here and I simply restored the
wreck that's an odd thing to hear it's
completely impractical
next time you're in the jetliner close
your eyes for a moment in your mind
remove all the seats and all the other
people and then open your eyes with that
vision and consider the expanse of the
living room it's a good environment at
million
[Music]
this is to food recall it to food
because it is food that is packed in a
tube YouTube pilots in the airport are a
lot like astronauts
they fly as high as 72 thousand feet and
there's no oxygen so they wear
pressurized suits and helmets could
breathe the only way to eat is to slurp
through a straw what we do here is we
make and design rations for the US
military
we are the only people in the world who
make it and these are tuples
we have approximately 19 different
varieties that we make here apple pies
key lime pie these two truffle mac and
cheese the products used to be very pure
aid they look a lot like baby food in
fact many of the pilots used to think
that Gerber manufacture the tube food
for them but about five years ago the
pilot came up to us and they wanted
something that had texture more like
regular food if you have a beef stew
they want this to be able to taste the
peas and the carrots and the meat and
the potato separately not just as one
mashed up product so Dan and his team of
food scientists in this lab set to work
we try to grind things up so that you
have a particle size that small enough
to fit through this tube yet still gives
the texture that the person would
normally have those tube food flavors
aren't the only thing they've developed
in this lab from powdered cheese to
instant coffee they've invented a number
of products that eventually made their
way into civilian life so is to include
our future there has been an effective
use of these products in this country
outside of the you tube but we can see
where it might be useful for like
student in a dormitory campers anyone
who wants to have an easy yellow Mageau
item you take you know probably the
worst herb in infuse kind of experience
and multiply it by about ten and that's
the potential that we're going into
[Music]
that's the voice of Justin Kibbey he's a
pilot my job title says hurricane hunter
pilot yeah he flies planes through
hurricane it's all in the name of
science
he works for NOAA the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration these
missions are for data gathering to track
and study hurricane paths and movements
but Justin Kibbey and I aren't talking
about data we're talking about what it
feels like to fly an airplane through a
hurricane
it starts to get cloudy and once you're
in the storm you'll start to hear rain
hitting the windscreen it can be very
loud it's surround you surrounded the
whole plane are the best we describe it
if you have ever lived in a house with a
tin roof it's hard to hold the
conversation inside these are the
conditions Hurricane Hunters fly through
every time they go on a mission because
the point of flying through a hurricane
is to fly through it and get to the hive
and he was telling me about the first
time he ever did that that was 2010
we're flying into hurricane Earl the
latest information we're getting about
Earl Jeff a hundred and thirty-five
miles per hour and still getting
stronger and then I remember breaking
out into the eye as a storm everything
just kind of stopped everything still
always stopped lighting stopped
pitch-black out you can see stars above
you really beautiful serene quiet and it
was a holy [ __ ] moment look just what do
we just do what just happened and a bolt
of lightning lit up the entire outbound
eye wall where I could see it visually
and also they go man that's going to be
scary it was a rough ride on the way out
but I'll never never forget it it was
probably one of the coolest that I've
been on
[Music]